all small towns have their horror
stories Tales of places plagued by
terrifying apparitions unseen forces and
something waiting in the shadows to
terrorize unsuspecting innocence
sometimes it's a bridge at the edge of
town where a man in a bunny suit stalks
wielding an ax and looking for drivers
who wander off of the main road
sometimes it's a cabin in the woods
rumored to house an old gnarled witch
who steals people away and throws them
into a giant Soup pot maybe it's a
cursed hotel where Wicked Spirits roam
the halls and the guests check in but
never check out or maybe like the little
town where 16 year old Mark lived it's a
haunted house ever since he was a little
boy Mark had been terrified of the house
at the end of the lane he walked past it
on his way to school each morning and on
his way back in the late afternoon the
side of it made his palm sweat his heart
beat just a little bit faster it had
once been a grand Victorian manner with
turrets and a wraparound porch painted a
brilliant white but over the years the
paint had faded to a dingy yellow
peeling away from the rotting wood there
were holes in the roof where the rain
and snow dripped through between the
shingles the windows were caked with
dust and grime obscuring anything that
might be hiding inside not that there
should have been anything there the
house had been abandoned for decades
still whenever he passed it Mark could
swear he felt the presence of something
in there pacing watching waiting for him
to come inside the stories around town
didn't help his parents told him to
ignore them said that people just like
to talk when there was nothing else to
do to make up things to be afraid of
because their lives were too boring
otherwise but he couldn't avoid it on a
boy scout's trip when he was 12 Marca
tried to cover his ears when the other
boys gathered around the campfire with
him and turned the topic the old house
but they teased and taunted him until he
listened they leaned in faces lit
ghoulishly From Below by the flickering
orange flames and whispered about the
ghosts that had taken up residence
inside the house a wealthy old woman had
lived there a long long time ago they
said she was cruel with a nasty temper
everyone in town knew to avoid her
knowing she would throw things at them
from her window shout at them even sick
her guard dogs on them but one group of
boys in town couldn't resist giving her
a good scare they dressed up in all
black Red Devil masks covering their
faces and broke into her house late one
night when she awoke they were standing
at the foot of her bed holding
pitchforks and telling her that they had
come to drag her to Hell her heart
stopped from Pure Terror at the site but
her spirit lingered in the house
swearing revenge against anyone who ever
dared cross her threshold again
especially teenage boys Mark didn't
sleep a wink the whole camping trip
after hearing that he swore then and
there that no matter what he would never
go into that house but everyone can be
bought and everyone has a price for Mark
that price was a car he had been saving
up as best he could but it was tough to
get a job with no way to transport
himself there and mowing lawns for his
neighbors wasn't the most lucrative gig
so when he learned that his neighbor
Oliver home on a break from college was
getting rid of his old car he begged to
buy it he doubted Oliver would go for it
knowing what a jerk the guy could be but
to Mark's surprise Oliver gave him an
offer I'll tell you why Oliver's face
broke into a sadistic smile I'll give
you the car if you can spend the whole
night in the House at the End of the
Street alone are you serious Mark
scoffed dead serious make it to Sunrise
without freaking out and bailing and the
car's yours we have a deal Oliver stuck
out his hand to shake every nerve in
Mark's Body was screaming at him to say
no but if he didn't three he wouldn't be
able to afford a car until he was in
college with a defeated sigh he took
Oliver's hand Dale but as night fell and
Mark prepared to meet Oliver outside of
the derelict old house he could feel
pangs of regret deep in his stomach what
was what was thinking was a car really
worth living his worst nightmare what if
Oliver didn't honor the deal or Worse
what if the stories were actually true
he swallowed the lump in his throat as
he shoved a sandwich into his backpack
he had food water a blanket a flashlight
and his phone everything he should need
to survive the night it would be fine he
hoped wasn't sure if he'd show Oliver
smirked as Mark walked up to meet him on
the rickety front porch well I did I'm
here Mark fidget had nervously staring
up at the house its Windows gazing down
on him like large dark eyes so here are
the rules you have to stay here until
sunrise you leave before then the deal's
off no car for you and you have to stay
alone no calling for help from your
little friends or your mommy and daddy
I'll be back to check on you in the
morning and make sure you really did it
got it got it Mark nodded good luck I'm
rooting for you really I'll return to
leave then glanced over his shoulder for
one final dig oh and uh watch out for
the ghost I heard if she gets you there
won't even be bones left overnight and
with that he walked away Mark stared
down at the doorknob preparing himself
to walk inside he could still leave he
could turn and run all the way back home
but then Oliver would be right and he
would be a coward no he was going to do
it he wasn't some scared little kid
anymore it was just a big empty house
nothing more he slowly turned the
doorknob pushed and with a long low
Creak the door opened to the darkness
within against his better judgment Mark
instinctively called out hello there was
thankfully no response just his voice
echoing in the vast empty room he let
out a small sigh of relief and pulled
the flashlight out of his backpack
switching it on he cast its beam around
the front room of the house Illuminating
water damage cobwebs that he could only
hope were no longer housing any spiders
and a whole lot of plastic wrapped
Furniture as he walked into the living
room he was struck by just how ordinary
it all seemed it was creepy of course
like any place made for a living that
had been deprived of its purpose for far
too long but it wasn't nearly as bad as
his imagination had built it up to be he
had been picturing black candles symbols
drawn on the floor in blood a skeleton
perched on the couch bats hanging from
the ceiling but there was none of that
no Ghosts no signs of danger this was
just mostly sort of sad once a home now
just a house emptied out and left to
Decay he could get through the night
just fine as soon as he thought that he
felt something Scurry across his foot
and let out a scream the flashlight
revealed it to be a large rat running
from his sudden intrusion and looking
for a place to hide he clutched his
chest catching his breath it's just an
animal it's fine it's not going to hurt
you he reminded himself now that some of
the mystery was gone he was starting to
wonder what the rest of the house looked
like what had once been breathless fear
was replaced with a certain morbid
curiosity if he had to be here all night
he might as well explore hey he thought
to himself with a smile exposure therapy
really works scared of a haunted house
just go roaming around inside the middle
of the night you'll be cured he sat his
backpack down next to the stairs keeping
a grip on his flashlight and began to
investigate the rest of his greatest
childhood fear he walked through the
dining room taking in the ornate
chandelier hanging from the ceiling the
long long table fit for housing at least
a dozen guests he wandered into the
kitchen the appliances Rusty from
neglect the oven and stove were someone
once prepared their nightly dinners all
the pieces of Life strewn about like an
unfinished jigsaw puzzle with no one to
pick up the pieces suddenly Mark heard
something coming from the other room it
couldn't be but it sounded like
footsteps on the stairs someone or
something walking down descending the
staircase toward him he held his breath
heart pounding so hard he couldn't hear
it in his ears the footsteps stopped and
the house was silent once again then
slowly deliberately he heard the same
footsteps heading back up until they
faded away too quiet to hear anymore
that wasn't his imagination he was not
alone in the house carefully he tiptoed
back the way he came careful to not make
too much noise walking across the
creaking floorboards when he reached the
stairs he saw no signs of anyone else in
fact there was nothing there at all wait
where was this backpack he scanned the
floor certain he had just overlooked it
forgetting where he sat it down but no
matter where he looked it wasn't there
his stomach dropped with a sudden
realization whoever he had heard coming
down the stairs must have taken it he
thought briefly about abandoning it and
just running out the front door and
never looking back but his phone was in
there if his parents found out he'd be
grounded for months not to mention he
wouldn't have a phone but what if
whoever took it was dangerous he
couldn't be sure but something in his
got told him he needed to go upstairs
and check it out he considered the
weight of the flashlight in his hand if
someone attacked him would it be enough
to defend himself he sure hoped so with
shaky hands and unsteady legs he began
to climb the stairs to the second floor
of the house maybe whoever had taken his
backpack was just as scared of him as he
was of them it was a comforting thought
though the Comfort was short-lived as he
started down The Upstairs Hall preparing
to search the first bedroom he heard a
door Creak open behind him he turned and
froze in wide-eyed Terror at the site
there was a figure there emerging from
the Shadows a pale woman with long dark
hair wearing a white nightgown reaching
out to him with a clawed
get out a voice rasped Mark shrieked
dropped a flashlight and tore back down
the stairs he ran to the front door but
as his hand touched the doorknob a hand
grabbed his ankle and pulled he toppled
over landing on the ground with a
painful thud please he saw him shaking
from Fear don't hurt me I'll leave I'll
leave I'm so sorry don't kill me he
braced himself for an unearthly voice
for pain but instead he heard gleeful
cackling he opened his eyes and saw
Oliver standing above him I knew you
couldn't do it you're such a chicken you
smirk what Mark stammered come on did
you really think I was gonna give you my
car are you stupid Oliver scoffed
clearly Mark followed the sound of the
new voice coming down the stairs there
was Chase one of Oliver's equally awful
friends he still believes in haunted
houses did you like my work I made
myself he held up what Mark could now
see was a prompt a mannequin dressed up
like some kind of ghostly woman he gave
it a good try but I think it's time for
you to run Longhorn now Oliver sneered
yeah Ron home Chase's taunt was cut off
as he fell against the banister suddenly
what the hell who pushed me he Whirled
around but there was no one on the
stairs with him still Mark could hear
the sound of footsteps hammering past
Chase and toward him and Oliver what
happened next shocked him to his core
Oliver was dragged to his feet by the
collar of his shirt pulled by an unseen
Force then with a loud Flack something
invisible hit him Square in the nose ow
he cried out but before he could react
anymore he was dealt another blow to the
stomach doubling over in pain what the
something swept his legs out from under
him and he fell hard head hitting the
floor with a crack then it was quiet
Oliver was still breathing but very much
unconscious blood trickling from his
nose screw this Chase yelled bolting out
the door as Mark scrambled toward the
door to follow him to run home before he
could be attacked next he saw his
backpack sliding across the floor toward
him thanks for the sandwich
a female voice said though he couldn't
see the source I love peanut butter
you're welcome he stammered before
grabbing his bag and sprinting all the
way home as the story of the Haunted
House Began to spread rumors in local
news reports alike reached the ears of
the SCP Foundation Foundation staff in
the area placed infrared cameras around
the abandoned house and the footage
captured a human Heat Signature whatever
was in that house it was no ghost using
infrared cameras to track the entity it
was quickly brought into custody before
long The Entity was opening up to the
foundation and she offered to cooperate
willingly in exchange for warm food and
shelter so the Invisible Woman was taken
to a nearby Foundation site and given
the official classification
scp-347
scp-347 is a young adult woman standing
at approximately 164 centimeters tall
for all intents and purposes she is a
completely average woman with one
exception she is completely invisible to
the naked eye this includes her body as
well as everything inside of it
including her blood skin and hair
samples though the cones and rods of the
human eye must be visible in order to
see
scp-347's Vision has registered as
normal following extensive tests she
refers to herself with the name Claudia
though this is assumed to be an alias
inspired by Claudia Reigns the lead
actor in The Invisible Man a real
identity if she indeed has one has not
yet been confirmed aside from her
invisibility
scp-347's only other notable traits are
an ability to pick locks a talent for
thievery and the ability to swallow
small objects in order to turn them
invisible and then cough them up at a
later time without any sickness or
discomfort she seems to Crave human
contact and socialization becoming
frustrated when she is ignored she will
act out in these cases by pranking
people and rearranging and hiding their
things when she is left alone with
someone who is sleeping she has been
known to stroke their hair touch their
face or tuck them in she does this she
says because it just feels right however
those it is done to tend to describe the
behavior as unnerving though she is
invisible in terms of visible light she
can still be seen using infrared or
ultraviolet cameras
scp-347 is currently contained at site
one kept in a 5 meter by 5 meter room
monitored with an infrared camera the
room has an attached bathroom complete
with a shower and bathtub a queen-size
bed two armchairs a desk and a swivel
chair several bookcases a TV and a DVD
player her bookcases are filled with
books mainly adventure stories romance
novels and art books as per her request
she has also been permitted DVD copies
of any movies or television shows that
she asks for as long as they predate her
arrival at the SCP Foundation new
releases may be added but only after
prior approval from the research team
though she does not frequently wear
clothes she is to be provided with any
clothing that she requests as well as a
collection of makeup and wigs she has
been encouraged to dress up to her
heart's content as it allows Foundation
staff to more easily gauge her location
at any given time while she is inside
the door to her room must remain locked
at least two staff members must check
her door every hour for signs of
tampering with the lock the door may
only be unlocked to allow staff in and
out for interviews research and the
delivery of meals and other requested
items she thoroughly enjoys human
company and will chat joke and even
flirt with those who visit her room she
is permitted to leave her containment if
and only if she is accompanied by a
staff member with at least level 2
security clearance as well as wearing a
layer of Grease paint on her face and
gloves on her hands this allows the
staff to see her hands and facial
expressions while she is out and about
staff are instructed to treat her with
respect and avoid making any rude or
crass comments about her invisibility or
her state of dress us or undress if she
attempts to escape she is to be returned
to her room and locked inside if the
staff are unable to detect scp-347's
location they will be given infrared
heat vision goggles and instructed to
keep an eye out for unusual phenomenon
Dr Wrights added an addendum to her
official file warning male Personnel to
politely decline any advances that
scp-347 makes towards them his note
reads she's an invisible kleptomaniac
when you leave afterward you're going to
realize three seconds too late that you
don't have your keys in your pocket
anymore and you will be held accountable
for whatever happens besides the last
thing we need is invisible pregnancy Dr
writes when she was first contained as
cp347 had regular violent outbursts and
displayed signs of emotional instability
including compulsive theft and
depressive episodes during which she
would give all surrounding people the
silent treatment her condition has
improved gradually over time with the
application of regular counseling
sessions intended to help her heal from
the trauma caused by years of complete
isolation and being unseen by the world
around her several of the research staff
studying Claudia have suggested that she
be introduced to other scps particularly
those who are humanoid and considered to
be non-threatening she might they posit
benefit from social interaction with
other anomalous beings that she can
relate and connect to this in addition
to her therapy could improve her mental
and emotional state significantly after
all just because she's invisible that
doesn't mean she has to feel invisible
too Claudia has expressed a great deal
of interest in this idea stating that it
would be nice to have some friends on
the inside who aren't being paid to talk
to her though no matchups have been
approved as of yet several anomalies
have been proposed should the program be
put into action
scp-507 was brought up in conversation
by more than one researcher given his
harmless nature friendly demeanor and
fascination with the Paranormal he
supported the idea enthusiastically
stating that he would be thrilled to
meet a real life invisible person
scp-343 has also asked to meet with
Claudia believing he can potentially
help her overcome some of her emotional
difficulties and offer her some much
needed Comfort other potential anomalies
to introduce to Claudia include scp-073
and
scp-056 though Claudius flirtatious
nature might complicate the latter
everybody wants to be known to be
acknowledged and recognized for the
person that they know themselves to be
for scp-347 it once seemed as if having
that simple desire that human need met
would be impossible for her but now For
Better or For Worse as long as she's in
the custody of the SCP Foundation
Claudia can make something approximating
a normal life she can at last be seen
now go check out scp-811 swamp woman and
scp-953 polymorphic humanoid for even
more lovely and not so lovely anomalous
ladies